if you remember the workflow of cloning
so the first step is to digest your
vector or your plasmid with restriction
enzyme and also digesting your gene of
interest with the same restriction
enzyme and thereby we perform a ligation
reaction which would put our gene of
interest inside the plasmid inside the
vehicle or inside the vector and then we
would perform a transformation reaction
the transformation would allow the
plasmid to be incorporated inside a
compatible bacteria which is able to
like take up the plasmid and allow the
plasmid to be expressed and then we grow
the bacteria in large amount in cultures
so in this video I will be talking about
the transformation process and how it is
actually done and what is the rationale
behind it so simply transformation of
plasmid means putting a plasmid which
may contain your gene of interest inside
a bacteria so the process is fairly
simple so the way we do transformation
is by creating small pores in the cell
wall and the cell membrane by intubating
it with divalent cation and a hit shop
so which would create transient pore in
the membrane and that would allow the
plasmid to be incorporated inside the
bacteria and later on if you give enough
time for recovery for the bacteria it
would kind of repair their damages and
it would grow in the media nicely and it
would also amplify the number of copies
of our gene of interest which is inside
the plasmid so let's just look at the
process step by step so the first step
of heat shock method transformation is
taking the plasmid which has your gene
of interest and adding that to a new
tube then we add competent cell most of
the cases the competent cell lines are t
h5 alpha and there are many other
components cell lines which are capable
of taking the or incorporating the
plasmid
now after that we incubate the plasmid
and the component cell mixture for
several minutes once it is chilled on
ice we quickly put it into a water bath
which is in 42 degrees centigrade and
keep it strictly for 90 seconds then we
take it out and put it back into the ice
so we have the temperature changing from
4 degree to 42 degree centigrade for
brief time point and then again back to
4 degree centigrade so this would create
a heat shock and after two minutes of
incubating in the ice what would happen
is there would be transient pour in the
bacterial cell membrane and the cell
wall and that would allow the plasmid to
get inside the bacterial cell then the
now the bacterias are in stress so they
need to grow and that's why we take the
transform and solution and put it into a
so same media now SOC media is basically
a media which is like enriched in
tryptone and a lot of glucose so this
media would allow the bacteria to grow
because if we indirectly plate it into
the plate so the plate already has some
kind of raised antibiotic resistance
right now the in order for the and rub
antibiotic resistance to work the
bacteria need to give we need to give
the bacteria enough time for these
antibiotic resistance protein to be
formed right so we have to incubate the
bacteria for 30 minutes or so so this
would give the bacteria sufficient time
to produce the product of the antibiotic
resistance gene now what we would do is
put the bacteria or played the bacteria
into 10 cm in 10 centimeter plate with a
desired antibiotic resistance let's say
ampicillin resistance so we would put
ampicillin in the plate and the bacteria
should have the ampicillin right then we
would inoculate the colonies
and spread the colonies all over the
plate and if we wait overnight and then
check the there should be colonies in
the plate and ideally this colony should
be the Transformers right but in order
to check it we should take out the
colonies and we can also calculate the
transformation efficiency by the
following formula that is shown in the
screen right now but we have to like
pick the colony out and then grow it in
large cultures and then it could be used
for downstream processes like plasmid
isolation and thereby followed by
sequencing to understand whether the
cloning has worked properly or not and
so on so forth so this is one of the
most important technique done in
molecular biology labs and I hope you
enjoyed this video if you like this
video give it a click thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe thank
you